commitment players heavily in everything
if you made a commitment when you hit
the rough spots not if when you hit the
rough spots your immediate thought is
how can I solve the problem if you've
not made the commitment when you get the
rough spot whether it's in marriage or
education or career or whatever your
first thought is man how can I get out
of this deal
and so that commit that plays a huge
role and is you know some people are
about as committed as a kamikaze pilot
on his 39th mission I mean they don't
really take it that seriously well you
know when the kids get out of school
then I'll really get involved in this
project we got so many things going on
right now Whateley out of school in the
summertime comes in and all really good
busy the kids get out school you know
what to say then well you know I didn't
realize that he had to take the kids
somewhere every day I had more time with
a risky way to get back in school and
then I really get busy the people who
wait for a Matilda to move out or Johnny
get on the day shift are the new models
to come out are the new mayor to come in
are for the new advertising campaign to
get started the people who wait on the
new senator in Washington are until
inflation slows are the rate of interest
gunned down the people who wait for
changes to take place out there before
they do the changin in here our flat
gonna end up getting cooked the rule is
simple you do it now you do it now you
just watch too amazing clip some Zig
Ziglar take the next three minutes and
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]